Chris Rock was slapped at the Oscars uh
there was a there was a an award that
was being handed out there do you
remember who won I won who won that
award yeah that was mine that was my
award yeah
um documentary summer love summer of
Soul number yes people always say
something I'm just going to do a sequel
for something
um yeah that was a surreal night but the
thing is is that when your name is being
read in the nominations you're not even
concentrating
on that like No Award I've ever been up
for have I've been clear and present for
like okay where's my name like literally
it's like okay remember remember and I
remember saying to my mom like wait are
they allowed to curse like that like I I
was distracted Yeah by I wasn't
distracted by what was happening because
I wasn't even focusing and we were so
far back in the theater
that but you know what I remember that
night you won yes you won yes you are
still winning